[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
your money your purpose
your mental emotional health
relationships hey we're talking about
the whole enchilada because you
matter i'm ken coleman host of the ken
coleman show on the ramsey
network joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil who's host of the table with
anthony o'neil
also a part of the ramsey network and we
are together for you
taking your calls your questions to help
you get where you want to be
the phone number to jump in is toll free
it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two
is the number let's start it off with
ricardo
who joins us in el paso texas ricardo
how can we help
yes sir hello and uh thank you for
having me on
i have a question regarding my
priorities
for my uh debt snowball and uh
overall uh get out of that uh plan
uh currently i'm 140 000
uh my income
is 100 000 a year
i have a family of four i'm the only one
working
currently i have a house that
the kitchen uh the remodel never got
done
and uh it's gonna be about ten thousand
to uh
repair it uh and i'm just trying to
prioritize uh
everything that i got um we recently
made the decision to go like debt-free
and we're just trying to get a good plan
of action
yeah so ricardo let me ask you this
question
we got a problem with anthony's mic
we'll try to figure that out
um and uh ricardo let's find out here
what the debt is made of 107
000 if i heard you correctly uh break
that debt down anthony could still hear
you but we'll get his mic fixed here in
a second
uh ricardo break down the hundred seven
thousand dollars in debt
no it's actually a hundred and forty
thousand oh okay i'm sorry
you're breaking up by the way too so
that while we're talking about me not
understanding you let's try to get that
phone
up to your mouth so you got 140 000 in
debt
break that down for us what is that made
up of
yes uh that's made out of uh
120 000 in
blooming state basically our home and
then
um 125 000 in student uh
loan debt and the rest is credit card
and medical bills
cool so how much is that ricardo um uh
on the
other that again i just got my mic fixed
so i'm hearing you better
yeah so basically it's it's about
roughly
around 110 115
000 for for my home okay and then it's
about 25 000
in uh student loan debt and then it's
another uh about 20 000
uh just in medical and credit card debt
cool so outside of your debt right now
we're going to take away the mortgage
all right
and so what i what i understand from the
question is
where do i prioritize my money do i take
care of the
the kitchen or do i take care of my debt
let me answer this question about
kitchen my guy uh is the kitchen
functional as far as in
is the oven working microwave sink is it
functionable
no okay so what's not functional about
the kitchen
basically uh about six months ago we
decided to
remodel it so we gutted it out and
you know it's just a poor choice
and we never um and now that we want to
get out of debt
um you know we're kind of looking at the
whole picture as
you know we messed up what do we do
the kitchen i got you in that recorder
but what's wrong with the kitchen
is the oven not working is the stove not
working do we have a refrigerator
there's no appliances
there's no plants and there's no
cabinets okay
all right so here's the thing yeah
that's not a kitchen that's a room yeah
exactly so so here's the thing you need
a kitchen man
okay um you you need a kitchen now you
don't need a laid out kitchen
right now in the process of of paying
out your debt but
um i i'm going to say that you're going
to continue your debt snowball as far as
in paying your minimum payments on all
of your debt
but you need to get your your kitchen
functionable and up and running all
right so you need to get your stoves in
there
um you need to get you know everything
functionable now
what i'm saying functionable is you need
to get your things in there so you and
your family can eat
and cook now you may not need to go in
there and put the most laid out cabins
in there
uh cabinets in there but you definitely
need to go ahead and get everything
situated in the kitchen so it can be
used wisely
so i'm gonna say your priorities are to
get your kitchen up
and running and functionable then once
you do that then you're going to come
over here to your debt and you're going
to attack
all of your consumer debt excluding your
mortgage
all right so you're not going to worry
about your mortgage you're just going to
take your student loans and your credit
cards and all consumer debt and you're
gonna
um line it up from smallest to largest
but kenny has to get the kitchen
yeah you know look here's it let's let's
define that okay
if we get the electric working yeah now
we have outlets yeah and we can plug in
a microwave
yeah and a fridge you don't even have to
have cabinets i know women out there
going ken have you lost your mind
yeah but here's the deal when we talk
about just making it
uh livable to where we can actually cook
something and we the stove is nice
yeah but a microwave in a toaster oven
kelly i think that would cover a lot of
things
ah you're gonna need a stove yeah we got
to give the latest you're the money guy
but i'm saying
bare bones yeah if we get the electric
working and we get water running a
faucet
of some type if we need that but but you
know you don't have to have the full
cabinets and all this stuff is all i'm
getting
yeah yeah you're right you're right ken
you're right but now as a man who's been
married 23 years i'm doing everything i
can to get that kitchen done pretty
quick
because because you want to make mama
happy and he's making good money man so
he's really
good pay that and pay all his debt and
be debt-free cash flow that kitchen
um and because you've already started it
looks like they can't already broke it
down so he's got ten thousand dollars
that he's got to kind of cash flow
through
and uh and then you know then you put
all that momentum
on the rest of it but he's in good shape
with the money he's making
if we separate the mortgage which he
told him to do he's in really really
good shape
really good shape and i i'm grateful
that he actually called in to ask this
question
you know because it lets you know that
he's intentional uh he is determined to
get there
and he's going to get there you know um
but um
get get the kitchen done because at the
same time let's be real ken
if your wife didn't have a kitchen and
you told her we don't pay off this debt
you may be sleeping on the couch bro
until you get the kitchen
and i i i agree with you i think i think
you're absolutely right
i'm just trying to help him go hey um if
we get
functionality in there and now we can do
something and actually live a little bit
more comfortably
then mom is going to be a little bit a
little bit more at ease
with suffering because it's no fun
living out of crates
and things of that nature certainly
cabinets go a long way uh
to you know making it livable but the
reality is
uh for him to realize that if he buckles
down like knock this out he's realized
some of the things they've done in the
past that they're not gonna do again
don't beat yourself up
the only thing i want to say to folks i
heard it on it anthony he's beating
himself up a little bit look
as dave says a million times he's got a
phd in dumb
we've all done it it's okay the light is
at the end of the tunnel you got this
ricardo thanks again for the call all
right don't move
he is anthony o'neil i'm ken coleman
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and 6 gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show coming
to you from our ramsey solutions
worldwide headquarters in nashville
thrilled to have you with us
the phone number to jump in on the
conversation about you
your life your money
relationships your purpose and work
we're covering it all i'm ken coleman
joined by
anthony o'neil and that toll-free number
is triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five let's go to charlottesville
virginia where anna joins us anna how
can we help
hi um i'm entering the third year of my
undergraduate career with the goal of
graduating from law school debt free
and my question is this i have the
ability to graduate in three years
but i'm wondering if it may be better to
take a part-time
senior year and leverage the resources
of my university and build a stronger
resume
and mature a little bit because law
schools typically want older individuals
anyway and i
want to get into a competitive law
school i love this idea tell me a little
bit more about the experience that you'd
want to gather in that year
well i'd like to be going as a part-time
student so i would also like to be doing
an internship of some kind
um working building my resume in the
workforce
um but also getting some more classes
under my belt and
expanding on my extracurriculars while
i'm there sure well
i love this idea the reason i asked the
question is i was curious about what you
would do
i'd like to know a little bit more
because here's what i don't understand
and maybe you can help me
i don't understand how one year is going
to make that huge of a difference as it
relates to well law schools want someone
older
i didn't really buy that as a great
reason because it's one
year so the difference between 22 and 23
or 23 and 24 to me
unless i'm missing something and again
i'm not in law school admission
but i'm i thought the idea of you
getting some really great experience
maybe working for a law firm if that's
what you're talking about as an intern
i love that but just taking one extra
year and
slowing down the education process to
get another
year of age i'm not sure that's a big
idea a big a deal as you think it is
but i certainly believe getting some
experience maybe working for a law firm
um or specifically a lawyer
uh or maybe you know clerking for a
judge or something anything like that i
think that's all wonderful and looks
really good
on the acceptance process but i'm
curious to know what specifically you
have in mind
to do besides the part-time school and
taking more classes
because i don't think taking additional
classes mean anything to law schools
i could be wrong well i'm kind of
trying to figure out how i can make the
most money to save up and
graduate debt-free from law school
because
i i'm worried about paying for college
my fourth year
um because i'll be paying for a lot of
my living expenses on my own but i do
have parents that will help me out
financially a little bit
um so i'm just trying to see maybe
what's the best path forward would it be
better to graduate just work full-time
from that
point on or try to get a better
internship so i have more experience so
i can have
a great lineup of jobs before i enter
law school okay if it's money ao you can
weigh in here but if it's if it's trying
to save up for law school i think it's
better to go ahead and get finished
with your four-year degree which you
need for law school
and then i'd work even if it took a
couple of years
to save up for law school because law
school a is not going anywhere
all right and b you're absolutely right
this is mr debt free degree guy right
here yeah yeah man
i was about to say i i want to see you
uh get done go ahead and finish it out
and then go out there and start working
and grinding and start saving for
uh for school that's that's what i want
don't don't
don't waste time in college trying to
prolong
you getting into a law school no
graduate
get a job if you're going to stay at
home be wise while you're at home
be stacking your money and then get into
law school as soon as you can and pay
for cash and 100 debt free
yeah thanks for the call anna you got
this it's going to be fun all right next
is
melanie in sacramento california melanie
how can we help
hi ken i hate my job but my degree
only allows me to do the one thing what
should i do
yo i'm sorry ken i never heard a call
that is she start off she didn't say hey
kim she said hey ken i
hate my job you know why because she
knows me
melody knows me that's what i do every
day i'm dealing with people that are
like i can't do this anymore
all right melanie let's let's uh let's
dig into this
um what is what is the degree
field uh or the degree in what field is
the degree in that makes you feel like i
can't do anything else outside of this
field
speech language pathology speech
language pathology all right
and i understand that's a very specific
career i get it
i get that the training for that is very
specific but when you say you don't feel
you can do anything else because you
have such a specific degree are there
ideas and things that you have in your
head and you go oh there's no way
they're going to take me
i wanna know what you're thinking about
well i try to see is there anything else
i can do with speech language pathology
and all they do is switch the place that
you work not what you do
but i wish i knew more of
what i really loved i probably i know i
like working independently
i'm detail-oriented i'm really organized
but usually any place that has those
qualifications
listed it they want some sort of
administrative degree or existing
figurine or a
technology degree not true not true do
you have evidence to tell me that i'm
wrong on that
you don't melanie yeah all right so
we'll get to that in a second let's go
back just a second why do you hate
your job is it the environment or is it
that speech pathology and all that's
involved there it just sucks the life
out of you i want to know
don't like um 90 of what i do
i don't like the content i'm also i'm
also extremely introverted
and speech pathology is people one after
the other
and so at the end of the day i'm totally
drained
at the end of the week i'm totally
exhausted fascinating okay
this is great why did you
think this is a two-part question
why did you think that you would love or
that speech pathology is a thing that
you should do
and then what's the 10 percent that you
don't hate give me those two answers
all right i got the degree because i
needed out of college
and i knew i could get a job with it and
i didn't really find out the full
content of what it involved
or second week of grad school and i
really should have job
shadowed someone i didn't know that
i don't know all right that makes sense
all right now what's the ten percent
that you don't hate
i don't hate the paperwork believe it or
not and
i like sub to some extent we're working
with articulation
but yep which is how a person produces
sounds
yep so here's the deal find it very
interesting i'm not surprised by that
can i tell you why melanie because you
told me and anthony two minutes ago that
you're
very detailed and organized yep so i'm
not shocked that you go
i like the paperwork but yet you put ao
and i in a job where we got to do
paperwork and we're banging our heads
against the wall
why because ao and i are not detailed
nor are we organized
no but you are so i would tell you
that there's a gigantic neon blinking
arrow saying
i'm really good at details i'm really
good at organization
i'll bet you you love work that drives
efficiency i'll bet you
love work that is systematic in nature
true or false true so you need to do
that and i've got news for you
you could go make really good money
being an executive assistant and it does
not require an executive assistant
degree
you have a really impressive degree just
because it's in speech pathology
doesn't mean that you can't do anything
outside of speech pathology
you are organized and detailed you'd be
a great project manager
you would be a great executive assistant
you might be somebody who works really
great behind the scenes coordinating
details
there's all kinds of work like that out
there melanie so here's the exercise for
you here's the homework assignment
you promised me you're going to say yes
and do this
yeah here we go i want you to go look
locally in your area sacramento
california look at job boards and i want
you to look for everything
that has the word detailed organization
process project project manager
anything that is organizational in
nature
that drives efficiency that creates
excellence melanie look at those job
descriptions
and say do i think i can do that do i
have the talent to do that
do i like doing that work does that work
produce a result that makes me happy
and when it goes yes ding ding ding go
apply for it you're qualified i promise
you
all right don't move ao anthony o'neil
ken coleman
with you this hour on the ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague
anthony o'neal we're taking you through
the shower triple eight eight two five
five two two five what are your
questions you got questions about money
you got questions about relationships
you got questions about
your work stuck in a dead-end job you
want to get promoted up the ladder to
get a bigger shovel
you got some i always like to bring this
up when ao sits uh sits in with me and
that's uh yeah
you're single got some uh relationship
money stuff as a single this guy's a
resident single expert i've been married
23 years i know
nothing and it's because i'm about being
single it's because i'm functionable
yes we now know uh he he
welcome to live radio sometimes we we
speak we
we professional speakers get all excited
and we take a real word
and we make up a word and you said
functionable but i told ao
at our entree leadership summit recently
in front of 4 000 leaders
my entire talk was about systemizing
talent acquisition and a couple times my
wife said
how many times how many times kelly you
were listening
three or four times i said systematize
so
i mean i've been there i've done it it
just happens and you just roll it here's
the good news
everybody knows what you mean and and my
wife even said to me she goes
i thought you might have been trying to
be funny about it because you kept you
kept
diving into it so kelly remembers that
so there you go thank you kelly
for keeping you know what though uh
here's a good thing cam we have a
functional couple
on the debt freeze we actually do live
on the debt-free stage in the lobby
is sean and emily here to do a debt-free
scream how are you
good how are you good where are you guys
from a little town called barney
missouri
bernie missouri is that like bernie is
in sanders
b-e-r-n-i-e like it's a name okay very
nice and uh drove all the way in i guess
yep about four hours this morning okay
oh cool
good that's not bad at all all right so
tell us how much
debt did you pay off about 76 000 76
000 and how long did it take 23 months
23 months and tell me your income during
that time
uh about 80 thousand okay so held steady
about 80 000. it took a jump and then i
kind of backed back down when i took i
actually read your book and uh took a
new career career path
did you really yes yeah well we've got
to mention the book so people can buy it
at home
the proximity price proximity yeah thank
you very much thank you my kids
appreciate that my wife needs a new pair
of shoes
uh okay so what were you making before
you jumped up to 80.
uh probably about 70. okay so you gotta
okay so good so somewhere between seven
and eighty thousand during that time
what do you do
uh i'm a youth minister now really yes
yeah and what were you doing
i was working in a factory uh ten hours
a day uh wasn't really happy with the
job yeah i
read your book kind of got close to some
people at our church position came
available and
i jumped on it well ao is a former youth
minister absolutely what do you love
most about being a youth minister
gosh it's the kids man like just
interacting with the kids and taking
them on these trips and and
seeing them grow it i wouldn't trade it
for the world
i'm a little um jealous right now
oh you are yeah the youth minister is
making 70.
i up was not making seventy thousand
dollars we
are making tickets oh okay
we haven't gotten to emily yet emily
what do you do i'm a second grade
teacher
oh good for you that's awesome how long
have you been a teacher um
five years five years that's so fun
favorite thing about being a second
grade teacher is
oh it's just every day is a different
day i never know what i'm going to get
into when i go to work every night
that's the truth
and the kids i just love them the kiddos
i love them okay tell us about the debt
what kind of debt was
it a little bit of everything student
loans credit card
medical debt uh cars car but two cars
two cars yeah yeah okay all right and so
what was the what was the turning point
what happened
23 months ago where you guys decided
this is this is done we're getting after
it
well actually i think our story kind of
starts about four years ago
uh we were attending church and and they
they
showed a promo for financial peace
university and
it kind of caught my attention and i was
like well okay i don't really need this
guy to tell me how to manage my money
uh so i was like but i thought the
thousand dollar emergency fund
sounded really good so so i did that and
uh
hold on a second you're telling me you
saw dave you're like i did this guy i
don't need this guy but i do like what
he's saying yeah
okay that's funny i said the same thing
when i first met him
then about two years ago our daughter
was actually hospitalized
and she wound up having to get air
backed and
when we got home we had you know about a
five thousand dollar deductible
uh then when we got back home we wound
up getting a bill in the mail for sixty
seven thousand dollars
for the area back uh where they had
billed insurance
but insurance had denied it so that was
kind of a little bit of a scary moment
for us and kind of showed us okay we
need to get our stuff together
and uh wind up resubmitting the
insurance com
to the insurance claim and and they
wound up accepting it but it kind of
opened our eyes
yes well that really scared you yeah wow
unbelievable yeah so over the last 23
months 76 000
is what you had to pay i mean but y'all
were making about
70. so that means y'all were like on a
mission
pretty much yeah tell us a little bit
about that journey like
how how did y'all do that in less than
two years i mean y'all were y'all were
living on half of your income
well it started out i think uh i sold
one of my vehicles okay uh so i was
driving a brand new jeep
uh and i had about ten thousand dollars
in equity in it so i sold it
took that ten thousand dollars and put
it on the student loans
wow and uh knocked two really big debts
off
right off the bat right off the bat kind
of started that debt snowball and yeah
our budget sticking to our budget has
helped tremendously cutting out the
things that we don't really need yeah
what were some of the things you had to
cut out
uh everything yeah i was gonna say
like we have an internet bill and that's
about it yeah i mean what about meals
because you got two littles over there
so what kind of meal situation what was
that like
we had a strict budget and um definitely
meal planned
um we meal planned for like a month and
you know
used as much as we could for each meal
and just tried to
to budget all that out yeah is there a
meal that you're sick of now that you'll
never eat again
probably spaghetti he loves spaghetti
before this now it's a no-go
yeah i can see the pain on your face
yeah that's fantastic i love that what
was the hardest thing
like what was the your friends looking
at you your family like what was the
the hardest thing to do over these 23
months
i think just stay content with what we
have
throughout it you know it
it's hard whenever you see everybody
else going and buying new vehicles and
yeah and things like that and i'm
selling my vehicle to pay off debt
and so that was pretty hard yeah who are
who are your biggest cheerleaders in
this process
uh i've got an aunt and uncle in up in
saint louis and they were pretty big
pretty big cheerleaders yeah i love it
in our church family a lot of people we
took this class
at church and so it was fun to talk to
people that we had taken the class with
and say this is where we're at
and and so that was that was a lot of
help with it too yes so before we get to
the debt-free scream because we
definitely want to hear this before we
go to break what
what's next you made these sacrifices
y'all people
people questioned you you sold your jeep
so you can be
a debt-free family but i just gotta ask
i mean what's the good thing that's
coming next that's going to put a smile
on y'all's face
the mortgage watch out well the man said
we're going to pay off some more
how much you got left 30. 30 000
yeah wow what's your payoff date yeah
i'm looking at maybe next summer
heck yeah unbelievable what wow we have
a small house
yeah that's okay though yeah but it's
about to be paid for
yeah and then that's a new that's a
whole new strategy never downplay the
size of the house
that's obviously a free house not a free
house debt-free all right real quick
encourage those who are early on in the
journey or they're considering taking
the journey what would you tell them now
at the end of your journey
it's worth it yeah i would tell them to
if they start it be patient
it's okay to be different um be content
we've really relied on god and he's
really worked on us to be content with
what we have i love it
it's more about that than us absolutely
it's about these two littles right here
let's get them in there
eleanor and ezra uh we've got some help
we're gonna bring them in here i assume
that eleanor has practiced the debt free
scream a little bit
she's a little shy okay that's okay all
right let's do this we ready family
there she is
and ezra is there with mom so here we go
all right
so we've got sean and emily from cape
girardeau missouri they paid off
76 000 in 23 months making 70 to 80
000 let's hear your debt free screen
three two one we're debt-free
hands in the air she did it way to go
sean
emily eleanor and ezra that's what it's
all about
beautiful young family debt free
oh yes all right don't move more of your
calls coming up this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
the ramsay show continues from ramsey
solutions headquarters in nashville
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil and we're taking your questions
what you got out there you're struggling
with the money questions
of life you're struggling with maybe
some relationship stuff maybe you're
struggling on the job
you got a tough leadership situation
maybe a little toxic environment
bored in a job needing more money
uh you're single and got some some money
questions and some unique situations
there anthony o'neil is our resident
single expert and of course as the
married guy i always love to hear what
he's gonna say
and uh it's always a great fun um
if you're living paycheck to paycheck
let me just talk to you for just a brief
second you know it sucks
at the end of the month you're barely
covering all the bills and you're never
getting ahead feel like you're just
stuck stuck stuck stuck stuck
you don't have to live like this we want
you to stop going in circles start
making progress
that's why we want to tell you about
ramsey plus this membership will show
you how to make the changes you need
to get the results you want with your
money why
because ramsay plus gives you complete
access to our best online money courses
like financial peace university and know
yourself know your money
these are tools that make sense and can
help you immediately so get out of the
cycle
start making real progress jump in for a
free trial
of ramsey plus today text the word trial
to 33789 text the word trial
to 33789
raleigh north carolina is where we go
next nate joins us there nate how can we
help
hi ken hi anthony uh love you guys
thanks for taking my call
thank you sir hey i'll try to be brief
and respect respected time i'm a 35 year
old military service member i'm married
we have six kids
we have 252 thousand dollars in debt not
counting a house
we make close to 150 000 a year
and we just finished baby step one
after i took on a second job trying to
uh
get the plane up into the air like dave
would say
and uh you know get a head start on baby
step one now we're in baby step two
we started doing a monthly budget and
allocation spending plan according to
the total money makeover forms
my wife is the free-spirited one and
uh i've took the financial peace
university a couple years ago too
and i've tried to show her the way
it's taken up until now until she
finally sat down with me
uh over the past months uh weekends in a
row
going over the allocation spending plan
the point is
every time we're going over the
allocation spending plan and budget
she she's the she's of the one of the
mind with uh
well we still got to do vacations
vacation she she just loves the
vacations
wants to take the family on vacations
and i
understand that and i'm the one who
is like well we can take vacations but
we got to stick to a really tight budget
and
we're living beyond our means no you got
253
000 debt you can't take not even no
cheap vacation
yeah i know i uh yeah staycation is an
article from days yeah
go ahead no let's let's talk about the
250 3000 real quick break it down for ao
what that's made of
what it's made of yeah the 253
total of 14 items uh one is definitely a
time share i've been listening to you
guys talk about in days
one is three of them are student loans
two cars what kind of cars several
credit cards
i got a 2021 nissan titan pro 4x my wife
has a 2020 nissan murano
okay what are the cars worth start with
yours
mine is worth uh worth blue
kelly blue yes around fifty thousand
fifty how much you owe right fifty five
zero how much do you owe on it
uh ten thousand more
goodness gracious what about your wife's
i'm guessing it's the same situation
what how much is hers worth uh
the murano hers is worth um
forty thousand how much yo on it
uh uh i think also five or ten grand
more
wait wait wait are these 20 20s in 2021
yeah
yeah i'm not sure that that kelly blue
blick value is accurate are you sure
that's accurate
i'm cuz how did you pay off 40 grand
almost 60 70 grand
in cars in less than a year
we traded in coal cars before so it was
rolled over these are rollover cars
rollover cars
okay all right so pretty much what we
have right here is
is um um if the kelly blue book is right
i'm i'm seeing about 60 60 grand in
equity
and you're uh 253 000 in debt right now
no they're upside down in these i
thought you said he oh no we're upside
down yeah i'm sorry i owe's ten more
than i twerk
oh okay okay okay okay okay so
maybe maybe the kelly blue book is right
yeah i shouldn't be so glib about that
but
but they're upside down in these cards
yeah okay but this is a this is a
marriage
we we've got some big time marriage
issues man yeah she's
you you're acting you're calling out
like well my wife doesn't want to agree
with me but
we got a 20 21 that either you all of a
sudden saw the light or she talked you
into this
so you're buying you know i mean i
understand what you're rolling these
cars over but man this is
you this has to stop and you guys this
is a marriage issue
oh i think you guys need counsel
i think you need counseling because it
is the counseling the next step
yeah yeah that that to me is is step one
because i don't it doesn't seem like you
guys are fighting and throwing pans and
pots at each other is that true
no no but i mean we've yesterday
listening to dave's talk
with uh colton from iowa city about the
same subject
um yeah i mean we were fighting you know
over
um the same way as as anybody who's
first starting out with
the month-to-month budgeting the first
few months are going to be painful
like he said like dave said yesterday so
that's that's what we're going through
so so let me let me talk to the money
side of things because i
i agree with ken and and here's the
thing with the money
not married i'm a single man and so i do
not want to give
marriage advice but one of the things on
a money side that i can give
advice to a married couple or a single
person
is that there has to be a clear vision
for the future
where where are we going babe what what
what do we
qualify and call success for our
marriage for our
family on the financial side of things
is that
so we can have financial freedom so we
can build our dream home
so we can take these dream vacations so
we can pass down wealth and legacy to
our kids
and if that is the case two hundred and
fifty three thousand dollars in debt
which half of it are in cars
okay yep passes and cars so immediately
i think when you go to counseling the
argument is not about money
money comes next we need to get a clear
vision of what do we want
where are we going when we get that
clear vision
all the other stuff is going to be an
easy conversation because now it becomes
all right does this take us to our
vision
or does it take us away from our vision
so that's one thing i would do second
thing from a practical tip
get rid of these daggone cards yes you
need to sell them
and this means that if you have to go
take out a loan for twenty thousand
dollars
to cover the differences you just went
from about a hundred and ten thousand
down to twenty thousand dollars right
there yeah that's huge
but your wife's gotta be on board with
this is the point or else you see what
i'm saying i don't know if you're in a
position where you just
if she's gonna agree with you to do this
yeah i mean ao is right
you you can make some major headway by
selling these cars and by the way now's
the time to do it because the market for
used cars
is at an all-time high but i would do it
soon but
could you go talk to her tonight i mean
let's let's be straight up with each
other
could you go in after this phone call
and go hey i'm selling both these cars
or she gonna fight you on this
uh no i i can't i can't even sell my
truck because i'm stuck with it i have i
have a camper so i need the truck to
pull it
you got a camper for what the family
yes are you living in it yeah no
no no dude get rid of the truck sell the
camper too well you made a mistake
telling us that
you dude the camper is cheaper to live
out of right now in in the
maryland area man listen man but you
just told me you weren't going to break
man
you making excuses i don't think it's
just your wife it's him too oh
absolutely right
well yeah you can't tell us on one hand
you're not living in the camper and then
say it's cheaper to live in come on man
listen this is this ain't easy you keep
listening to the show and then at one
point you're going to decide it's time
yeah
ayo is done i'm done i hit mute he's
done he hung up on him he hung up
he's he's had it i'm sorry ken no
apologies
hey he is ao i'm ken coleman want to
thank uh
you america for listening this has been
fun
and this is the reindeer
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermzyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
life
i'm kid coleman host of the ken coleman
show on the ramsay network
joined by my colleague anthony o'neil
host of the table with anthony o'neil on
the ramsey network as well
as ramsey personalities we are your
hosts this hour
triple eight two five five two two five
triple eight
eight two five five two two five what's
your question
you need uh just to talk you need some
tactical advice whether it be on
money your work your relationships
whatever it is we are here for you it is
a free phone call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's start it off this hour in fort
worth texas where asa joins us asa how
can we help
hey guys anthony and ken thanks for
taking my call you bet what's up
uh not too much just uh living life just
trying to get things figured out
so uh about a year ago i started out
beginning at 2019 i was actually waiting
tables making less than 25 a year
and by the grace of god i ended up
getting into
a previous job i had they called me back
and i ended up getting a job back
so i went from making below 25 a year to
around 52.
okay uh so you know it's just a lot of
increase and it's been super awesome so
immediately as soon as i got the pay
increase i just started hitting it hard
i mean paying off debt so i never had
the chance to address
you know my wife and i collectively lost
through between the two of us paid off
our credit cards just being the last one
this past week actually so about 17 000
in credit cards and
mixed up other debts that we had right
now though
uh my wife and i ended up buying two
cars back in 2019 i've got a 2019
baltimore city
jeep and so not the best
ideas back then but desperate times and
you know you just really
well i really need the car at the time
to keep working so
right now we're facing is the situation
of
we had a personal one because she had
consolidated so we had about 24 000
right now we just restructured that loan
because it was killing her
like 24 interest rate and we just got it
down to seven
shocking i know uh but we got that
restructure recently which is great
because now we can get it out together
my question is though i still owe about
26 of my car
i tell google it says it's around 20 000
worth
if i sell it private and she has her car
which is about 24
and i literally just brought it up today
with her because i was watching uh
anthony's uh 10 things not to do with
your money on youtube
and i kind of cut the idea in my head
like you know what if i were to sell my
car
you know try to get as close to breaking
even as possible and then maybe just
turn around and get a five thousand
eight thousand dollar car
and just see if we can try to work it
down from there
yeah i'm just uh you know i was trying
to get some advice because she's
totally against me selling my car right
now like she's totally against it i was
like
you know just think about it you know
there's there's you know don't just look
at it from hey we need two cars look at
it from
what's the possibilities for the long
term because
i don't want to you know i don't want to
be in deadliest my life i really want to
retire before i hit 45
but you know gotta have goals but i'm
just trying to see you know what is a
good way i can try to address this with
her and show her the positives of
you know maybe not just you know selling
a car just to not have another car but
downsizing in the desktop
you know it's such a great question and
i really want ken to come in and talk
about this from a
husband perspective because i really try
to make sure that i'm careful and not
giving
marriage advice because i'm not married
uh but
there is a level of
again being clear on the ultimate
vision like bay where are we going do we
want financial freedom and if we want
financial freedom
then there's going to be some things
that we have to do that we will not like
to get there hence one of the things
will be
selling the car um total debt what's the
total amount of debt you have excluding
your mortgage bro
real quick so without the mortgage
already calculated uh both of our cars
plus the
uh loan that we just restructured it's
about 74 000.
okay and then what's your total
household income again
uh we're right now with my income going
up for about
130 i believe 130.
130k cool so with this kind of income
74 000 in debt if you all really follow
what we teach here in the seven baby
steps
you can be debt-free within the next two
and a half years
because of that right if you cannot pay
off your car within two years
uh because your cars combined are not
above your household income 50 of your
household income
so i can rock with it but where you get
the ding is
you know you got two you should be paid
off within two years
so i'm in line with you of selling the
cars
and buying a cash car do you have
anything in savings right now
not yet literally just everything we've
had as far as has been going towards
paying off the debt like oh yeah
again you just paid off the last credit
card so right now it is
sort of the savings like do you have a
thousand dollars in your
account though not yet
we're just about to get started on that
she's been reading the uh the
you know total money makeup i haven't
read yet i'm just watching those videos
yeah so that's
inspiring and great man i appreciate
that i want you to watch our videos
uh but real quick a thousand dollars is
babysit number one
and then after that you go into babysit
number two and you start paying off all
debt using the debt snowball
then you go into a fully funded
emergency fund so i want you all to stop
not stop but paul's putting extra money
towards your debt and i want you to put
a thousand dollars in your emergency
fund
because it's not a matter of if
something within the next 90 days
something possibly will come up man
let's be honest
and so i want you to have at least a
cushion uh to where you can pull from
rather than having to go into debt
uh but ken how does he have this
conversation uh with his wife
as a husband because you know i'm i'm a
little immature in that area because i
you know when i hear people say that i
just
i just want to tell my wife this is what
we gonna do yeah
and that and that's uh that's a single
man talking uh
who has no experience with this you know
the question i have asa is this
when you said a moment ago that your
wife doesn't want you to sell your car
what let's be real specific is she like
jumping up and down telling you you're
an idiot or a [ __ ] or threatening you
or blah blah blah blah or she just
shared an opinion she's like i don't
think you should do that
give me give me the level so we're
pretty level-headed so she's definitely
giving me uh she's not like over top
crazy about it she's just like giving
her opinion
right because she doesn't want to be
without cute cars for a while i get it
but i'm not accusing you of this but i'm
telling you that i've been here before
as a married man
sometimes stacy may just make an
offhanded opinion and i'll use it as an
excuse not to do something i know i
should do
and she's not telling me not to do it
she's not even telling me she disagrees
sometimes we make excuses because it's
like well i want to do this but gosh
this will be uncomfortable
but because of one conversation asia my
wife said i
don't know how smart that is because we
need to oh you're laughing
that means ace i might be on the mark
yes or no
uh come on like yeah because you know
honestly like with everything just
throwing everything our guests recently
like
i didn't realize how much it was hurting
her personally because she likes to go
and do things
i get it but that's an excuse i get it
so here's the deal
you just admitted it that's a long way
of saying you're right ken here's the
deal
sell that car go get something cheap
that's gonna take a
tremendous amount of debt off do exactly
what ao said but sell the car man
sell the car you can always get a nicer
car later but we make excuses sometimes
yeah
because we don't want to do it yeah we
say we want to do it
but we don't really want to do it and so
we'll use somebody else's opinion
as an excuse that's not fair to them and
that's not the right thing to do
work the baby steps you guys are just
now getting into this they work
don't stop doing them they always work
every time
when people commit to them and finish
the baby steps
this is the ramsay show
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsay solutions
studios in nashville and uh anthony
o'neil
ken coleman with you for this hour it is
a free call triple-a 825-5225-825-5225
let's go
to richmond virginia where austin joins
us austin how can we help
anthony ken it's a pleasure to talk to
you guys can hear okay yes sir
hey so um i'll give you a little bit of
background um
i am 100 debt free um
my fiance she's still in school she has
um she has a little bit of debt she has
about 2 000 on credit cards
7 000 on student loans but you know
she's
she's graduating in december and she's
you know she has school paid for her
mother works for university so she gets
free tuition so
um we are pretty much both on the same
page
with as far as debt i know i am i
do not like that yeah no debt no no like
you guys say
she is almost on the same page she's a
little more tolerant than i am
but um i guess the big question is we
are you know making
we're planning our wedding right now and
uh
we have a strict i have we have a strict
10 000 budget
and um she is starting to
get a little you know iffy about the
budget the closer we get at first she
was like
oh man yeah yeah yeah but now she's
you know we're starting to make some
real decisions she's going out wedding
dress shopping and you know we have
um a certain amount budgeted for her
wedding dress and she's i guess she's
kind of scared
and she's like oh no i don't know what
wedding dress i'm gonna get so i guess
the real question
is and it's starting to cause a little
bit of calm in our relationship so
i guess the question i'll boil it down
to is is compromising on the budget
for the wedding okay for the happiness
of the relationship
let me ask you this question awesome do
you have any room to compromise
on the budget um
maybe a little bit i'm trying to no
seriously
do you have any room to where you can
go up and give like an extra couple of
thousand dollars
comfortably where it's not going to hurt
you all's future you're not robbing from
your emergency fund like is
it's can you maneuver some things around
uh for the sake of this wedding
that's a simple yes or no question yeah
yes i can
how much how much more is that honestly
um probably about maybe i could make a
thousand dollars on there
so but i don't know you know where it
stops if i compromise some dress
do i have to compromise on something
else and i don't know where to get
into it i don't think and can correct me
if i'm wrong i don't think
you tell her what to do i think you tell
her hey babe we set out we agreed on a
ten thousand dollar budget
i hear you i want this day to be
absolutely amazing for you
um so i i went back to the budget i can
squeeze out another thousand
i don't know what you can squeeze out
but the key thing here is we're
not going to rack up any debt and we may
not have everything we have
but you can choose how you want to spend
11 000
and let her choose what she's going to
compromise on
but i think as a man you are showing her
that i'm trying to make this the
best way possible but also i want you to
see that i'm trying to be a good steward
with the financial resources
right and then you put you put it back
on her to be like all right i'm gonna go
buy a 3 000
address but then i may bend over here um
and go from there what is specifically
you guys have talked about this is there
a specific
number in her mind or a specific item
and will the thousand dollars i love how
eo walked you through this that was
beautiful is that going to solve it it
doesn't sound like it does to me
like it solves it because you're like
well what happens when she comes back
for a thousand more
that's the way you basically reply to
that so that leads me to believe
there's been a couple of conversations
and i want to know what specifically is
going on
here how much more are we talking about
where does she want more money
i don't know i think it's i think it we
we have pretty much everything set we
have the venue and the
caterer i think she's kind of just
afraid of the um of the
of the unknown she's afraid that she'll
try on a
you know three four thousand dollar
dress and fall in love with it
um and then be able to get it because
i guess we're restricted to the budget
okay so
okay this is great that's what i wanted
to know okay
uh if you gave a thousand dollars more
because that's your limit would that get
her to where she
would be able to afford the three
thousand dollar dress
um maybe but she hasn't gone wedding
dress shopping yet that's my old point
okay she needs to go shopping first and
start looking at stuff and getting
a range of stuff if i let's let me tell
you something ao and i
both love clothes okay no shame on our
game we like a nice suit both of us
we come from the church world ao we like
custom suits we've we've done that
before nice students but here's the deal
i go look at stuff and look at materials
and look and shop
and then i start pricing and then when i
start pricing i start going oh
i can get this level of a suit for this
i could get this level for this
if i don't want to spin this what do i
do i start changing the material that i
might
she needs to go dress shop this
conversation doesn't go any further
until
she goes dress shopping and she starts
looking at what she
likes and what she would feel beautiful
in and let's put some real pricing out
there otherwise this conversation
doesn't happen anymore well let's let's
let's add to this ken okay
because uh if you tell a woman to go
dress shopping and then let's talk about
the budget
she look at all the ladies out there
looking at me like i know where
anthony's going
she's gonna find a ten thousand dollar
address no and come back no she's not
gonna do that yes she will no
come on now so this this this is my
suggestion i think y'all need to come up
with
hey bae you can spend three thousand
dollars on your dress
now go find a dress that you like within
that believe it
i'm assuming austin and i appreciate
that ao but for everybody who thinks i'm
tone deaf
she's already said to you i'm scared i'm
gonna try out a 3 000
or 4 thousand dollar dress she knows
what it cost
but she needs to go out there and start
trying some stuff on is my point yeah
but you can go on amazon and get it
dressed for 500
but she's not going to that's not going
to happen
you know what i'm saying i mean look
i'm just saying you could find a dress
in in any budget kit
i'm just saying i think for her was what
i feel as if
this younger generation hears from their
peers oh you
you're gonna spend about five six
thousand dollars on the dress of your
life and you're only gonna wear it one
day
why spend five grand on the dress you're
only gonna wear it one day um
that's my thing it's all relative it
really is all this is relative but
that's probably why i'm still single
because i ain't
yeah you're yeah you're all carrying on
with confidence about wedding dresses
i'm over here going man i've been there
done that
okay i've already been through all this
i like how you walked him up to the
point of going look
here we are this is our first major
money discussion we're about ready to
get married
right and money is the biggest money and
kids
and i throw faith in there those are
your big tension points in marriage
right that's good and if he's saying i
can only go a thousand more i thought
that was great that you walked him up to
that and i would say to that young man
you can make more money go ahead and
kick in a thousand dollars but they also
need to actually go
dress shopping and she might think three
or four thousand is her
her lane she might see something for two
i don't know
i haven't checked wedding dress prices i
i've been married 23 years i don't have
a clue
okay but what i'm saying is is that
they've got to get to a level of true
understanding here i need to understand
you you need to understand
me let's figure out what really really
matters here i want you to feel
beautiful i want you to look beautiful
i understand it's a big day i'm excited
about it but
we got to go see what's out there and
not just assume that well i'm going to
need
more money because i've started looking
into it that's what i'm
this is a moment for this young couple
they got to really figure this out
yeah because you don't want to be you
know the last thing you want is her
in the back room of the church crying
crying
because she didn't get the dress she
wants ah
man i want to say something right there
but i can't that's probably a good idea
i don't even know where you're going but
it's probably a really good idea let's
change gears hey
the housing market is hot hot hot right
now i mean it's crazy white hot
and your house could be worth a lot more
today than it was when you bought it
this means your old insurance policy
might not give you enough coverage
anymore either
so what's the point of paying for
insurance that won't swing the cost to
repair rebuild your home
now some policies will automatically
rise excuse me raise your coverage to
cover rising home prices but not all of
them
so we want you to check out our friends
that are endorsed local providers
these independent agents will compare
multiple policies to find the best
coverage for your home
and your budget text the word home to
33789 and talk to a trusted insurance
pro
text the word home to 33789 to make sure
you have the right coverage
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman ramsey personality joined by my
colleague and ramsey personality
anthony o'neal and we're here taking
your questions
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to elijah in
kansas city kansas
elijah how can we help hello
i'm wondering if i should buy it i'm
wondering if i should buy a truck this
year or next year with the amount of
money that i make okay how much money
you make
um i'm just 16 just started working this
summer for my dad's company
i should start making probably five to
seven thousand dollars
just this summer and then hopefully the
same next summer
and then i have so many savings too how
much do you have a savings already
i have two thousand dollars in savings
okay cool what are your parents saying
what what
when you talk to your parents what are
they advising you to do
um use this because we have a van use
that car
as much as i can until
so i can save up more and more okay and
so
save up to go buy another car or save up
to have this money go towards your
college experience
i don't know if i want to go to college
oh okay what kind of truck are you
thinking about price wise
well if i'm thinking about a truck or i
want something that'll pull a trailer
why do you need to pull a trailer yeah
why why do you have a trailer or what
trailer you pull in what
what for on the side i mow yards on the
side
too nice so the trailer's got the
lawnmowers and everything on it
i love it yeah yes yeah all right so
again
what's the price point have you done any
research on a truck that again
um i mean this isn't a massive trailer
so you know what kind of truck are we
talking about price so again what's that
price you're looking at
um probably ten to fifteen thousand for
a truck man
yeah trucks are expensive man i'm
looking at him
it's gonna be he can't find something
around five and seven i would say that
i'm just saying i'm not surprised that
it's 10 to 15. i mean anything
less than 10 you're going to be crazy
high miles pretty old is that right
elijah yeah i want something that'll
last me a couple like five to ten years
i would do a little bit more research i
mean for for a 16 year old
i'm comfortable with you spending in
between five and seven grand on your
first car
uh if your parents want to chip in the
other three grand to get you over to 10.
i'm okay with that but for you
i want to see you right around five max
7 000 on your first vehicle um
and i think you can be there by the end
of this summer
um you know i definitely understand
about the van
and not being able to pull it as much
with uh
for your your cutting grass but i mean
i agree with your parents i would try
and use this van as much as i possibly
can to save up a money and then
once i come up with the five to seven
grand if my mom and dad want to if mom
and dad want to match you
to help you get to a little bit more
better car with less mouths
i'm cool with that but for you no no
more than five and don't get completely
married to a truck
too because there are some suvs that um
you got a v8 in them v6 have plenty of
juice
to be able to pull a trailer so it
doesn't have to be a truck i get it
you're in the landscaping business
cutting lawns everybody feels like they
need a truck i get it
my kid wants a truck right now i'll tell
you what yeah i mean listen trucks
trucks hold their value your otis let me
talk to him i'll change this what are
you going to talk him into i'ma tell him
no
this is fantastic have you ever dinner
tonight
i didn't realize my parents i didn't
realize my parenting issues were as
simple as getting an ao to talk to him
i don't know yeah i get you all right uh
triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number
crystal's next in chicago illinois
crystal how can we help
hi ken hi anthony hi you guys are doing
well
yeah we are what's going on um so i'm
calling because i just received a
new job offer um it's doing something
that
i believe i will actually really enjoy
and right kind of aligning with my
talents and passion nice but i am
terrified
because um the initial start of the
position
would require me to take a pay cut for
a potentially eight weeks but the
earning potential after that
is pretty limitless and so i am just
i'm nervous about accepting the offer
i don't want to you know leave my job
because i it's more of a
secure position right now and so i just
don't know
what to do sure you do keep someone to
help me kind of talk
through oh yeah so this is a simple
simple exercise this is head and
heart in a wrestling match that's all
this is
and you just said because you know your
hearts
let me take a guess your heart is saying
take the new job because it's something
that's in your sweet spot as i teach
where you use your talent what you do
best
to do work you love your passion to
accomplish results that matter to you
mission and oh by the way
it's limitless income so there's that on
top of the whole
the whole sweet spot says your heart's
going take the new thing but your
brain's going
that's not smart it's risky we got a
stable job with great benefits
probably sounds annoying like that voice
too huh
right right exactly so i tell people to
follow their heart and let's just walk
through
why we need to get our brain connected
to the heart
can you absorb okay can you absorb or
another word is
can you manage through an eight
week which is two months pay cut
yes um yeah yeah i mean i think
putting writing it all down putting it
down on paper so it just took process
yep my husband and i are on baby step
two
um so we're almost out of baby stuff too
we have about
20 000 more dollars to to pay off we've
done really well so far and so
yes i just keep thinking that would
obviously push us back
you know those two months maybe three
months depending
um and we've built so much momentum so
that's why i think i'm nervous
but if we just hunker down
even more i mean i think it's definitely
doable it is doable
um but again it's just it's just who i
am i'm i have that scarcity mindset so
i'm
i'm not yes yes but don't beat yourself
up that's that's human that's normal i
get it especially when you're in the
middle of paying off
debt you're in your baby step two which
this is really great ao because we had a
lot of people that listen to the rams
show that'll come over to our shows yeah
and they'll cover the ken coleman show
and go well ken's trying to help people
discover their dream job and make a
reality but i can't even think about the
dream job i can't even think about
making progress in my career when i'm on
baby step two and that is
absolutely categorically false i agree
and crystal you're the proof of it
so here's the deal you and the hub sit
down
on paper we adjust our budget just like
we've taught you to do
when any other life situation happens
and we adjust the budget
for eight weeks maybe nine weeks maybe
12 weeks
we adjust the budget for the new job and
the reason we do that we hunker down
is because it is this move that is not
only going to be
on purpose for you doing something in
your sweets about what you were born to
do and you're going to
love it you're going to work harder
you're going to make more money oh
that means we're going to actually get
out of debt get the emergency fund the
15
retirement we're gonna slide right
beautifully into baby steps four five
and six
way faster because of this job is that a
true statement or a false statement
that's true then that's what we focus on
and we sit down and we go this is an all
this is a short term
step back in salary
for a short term increase like
it's not long term you're doing this for
eight years to do it for eight weeks two
months
maybe three months do you believe that
you can crush this job
oh certainly that's my girl right did
you hear that a.o
she said she said oh easy certainly
so you and the hub start thinking about
all that increase financially and how
that gets us through baby step
three and babysit two and three faster
bigger shovel you ever heard dave talk
about the bigger shovel
yes you just got yourself a bigger
shovel by getting promoted
you just promoted yourself crystal now
are your head and heart aligned
yeah definitely because here's the deal
it's natural to be afraid
well we must call the fear out and we
must ask ao
is fear telling me the truth so good
well let me tell you this
if i get up to the edge of a cliff and
fall over or i get to the edge of the
cliff and fear says
if you fall over you're going to die
fear's telling me the truth
[Laughter]
but if but a fear saying you can't win
in your sweet spot you can't make that
money you can't do that job that you got
the talent for
fear's lying to me in this case crystal
fear's lying to you trust your heart we
got on paper
how we're gonna do this now the head
needs to shut up
and listen to the heart walk forward you
guys are going to be debt free before
you know it
and rolling through the baby steps and
the best part
you're going to be doing work you love
making the contribution that you deeply
want to make way to go crystal
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america this is the ramsay
show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague
anthony o'neil and we are taking your
calls this hour
what do you need to talk about you want
to talk about your money you want to
talk about relationships you want to
talk about your work oh how about that
last call that's always fun we got
somebody going should i take
a temporary pay cut to make more money
in the short term love those questions
do you love the job
uh listen the big shovel stuff you want
to know how to make more money to get
out of debt and do work you love i'm
your guy
that's what i do for ramsay solutions so
we'd love to have you jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number let's go to
grand rapids michigan where michelle is
on the line michelle how can we help
hi guys um i actually have a great
question
for anthony i've been trying to call in
when um
he's been on great so i have a
i have two student loans that were
from a private lender and they
are now in collections um
and i make like the minimum
payment monthly for them which doesn't
even cover the
interest um and
i just don't know do i continue to pay
that monthly
amount or do i
hold off and try and get a big lump
sum so i can offer that to them i just
don't know where to go with it
yeah so let me ask you this question um
are these only two uh dead items that
you have like what other debt do you
have
they are not okay i have
um i'm normal i guess
so i have uh some credit card debt
some medical bills okay
and a vehicle what's your total income
right now
my our household income
is about 85 000. okay 85k
all right sounds good and so if you had
to run up it's a ballpark
what do you say how much debt do you
totally have
including the two collection items that
you just said with student loans
um
including the student loans i have about
a hundred thousand okay a hundred
thousand are you married
yeah okay cool so it's uh you and your
husband does that hundred thousand
include his debt as well yeah
okay and eighty-five thousand dollars
um how much is your household income is
it eighty-five that's our house
yeah okay cool so here's the thing um
how you pay off your debt uh michelle is
not gonna change
all right you're gonna pay all your debt
from scholars to largest you're gonna
line it all up
and you're gonna make the minimum
payments on all of them and then attack
the first one
now when you get to the student loan
ones uh private loans
yes uh if you are there in the
collections item
i will go ahead and ask what's what's
the best you could take on it
now here's the thing student loans are
going to be hard to get settlements i
mean they're
especially federal ones um sometimes
private will move a little quicker on
them uh but
i would definitely say it's gonna be
it's it could be a little
it could be a little hard i'm just gonna
be real with you uh but if you call them
say hey i only can give you for example
if it's five thousand
i only can give you three thousand um
you can stick to it
uh but in the meantime you know you just
gotta pay it
and i hate i hate to say it if they are
not willing to settle uh
don't sit there and let it just sit
there uh waiting to see if it will
settle
nah just attack the debt uh when you get
to that
to that part of the death snowball so
that's what i would definitely recommend
and america hear me clearly
stop being lazy okay um
and i get it you know we're looking for
a good deal we're looking you know
how do we save money and i totally
understand uh but oftentimes i hear a
lot of people say this
man it's in collections i'ma wait until
they give me you know a huge discount
well here's the thing
you're gonna be waiting a long time okay
bottom line
there are some collection agencies
especially on credit cards they will
actually work with you on them
uh but i don't want you waiting on them
uh when you get to that point in your
debt snowball you do what you got to do
to get
get rid of it so you can get to the next
debt so and the quicker you can get
through your debt snowball the quicker
you are to financial freedom and peace
um but don't wait you know so yeah
yeah good stuff all right let's go now
to ned in salt lake city ned how can we
help
uh hi guys hey how are you doing today
great what's going on
i'm doing all right well i've kind of
got a
interesting question um about eight
years ago i went through a pretty
pretty big life change i was involved in
a pretty bad uh
work related accident that uh left me
legally blind
as well as pretty hard of hearing
because of that i had some good
disability insurance and so
i've been on kind of a combination of
insurance payments and social security
disability for the last few years or so
um about two maybe three years ago
um i returned to work part time
in kind of a new career avenue um
as a an adjunct instructor an adjunct
teacher
professor in chemistry right which was
the subject i was trained in
and i ended up being pretty good at it
and now i'm starting to get some
offers i guess or some interest
and doing it full-time um
and i don't know i guess it's it's
brought up kind of a
interesting dilemma from me what's the
dilemma um
the dilemma is that actually with the
part-time work and the disability
payments
i'm actually able to live a fairly good
bringing a pretty
fairly good income and going to work
full-time would mean having to leave
behind the disability payments
and possibly taking in less income
well then and then this is really not a
dilemma
this is you going what do i really want
to do with the rest of my
professional life i mean this comes down
to
d it comes down to what do i really want
to do
and then i've got to look at the numbers
and so i get what you mean by dilemma
your brain's telling you to stay
part-time because there's more
money and you're in your heart's going
let's go full time and teach i actually
like it i'm really good it's like the
last call i took on this
it's a head and heart thing they're
arguing with each other aren't they
oh big time yeah what's your heart
telling you tell everybody
uh i don't know what my because my
head's so loud right now tell me that
okay let's go the easy route i know what
your heart's telling you
your brain just told your heart not to
tell that's what just happened
everybody knows it what's your brain
telling you ned
my brain is telling me that my physical
situation is also
not guaranteed to stay stable that's
fair
it may deteriorate yeah may deteriorate
to the point where i can't do it anymore
have the doctor told you that
yeah okay so wouldn't we go back on
disability at that point
um from what i understand it would be
very
difficult with the insurance company
i've tried to explore that and
trying to get a straight answer out of
them is pretty much like trying to get
blood out of a rock
yeah i get it well um have you looked
into what full-time chemistry
professors are going to make
so you use the word possibility it would
be less money
is it truly less money or is it about
the same using your part-time
adjunct professor money plus disability
and social security
is it truly apples to apples or is it
ones
higher than the it's less take-home
it's but
i don't know part of me is also
part of me is also looking at it as
kind of proves that uh that explosion
didn't finish me off eight years ago
do you feel that emotion ned
yeah yeah i do do you know what that
means
that your heart is telling you
you want to get back in the game your
heart wants to go teach chemistry but
your heart really wants to say hey
i overcame an unbelievable
devastating situation and i'm back
here's what i want you to do
get multiple pieces of advice on the
disability talk to your doctors
but i think you follow your heart you go
full time as a chemistry professor
make some financial changes do whatever
you got to do i think your heart wants
to get you back in the classroom you can
feel that right there it's all over you
ned
because you want to make a difference
i'm so proud of you
what a stunt hey i want to thank our
producer ben hill our associate kelly
daniel
my colleague anthony o'neil most of all
you america
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsieshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out
to have a conversation about life money
working on purpose relationships
mental emotional health just
about being on purpose i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
anthony o'neal and we are together to
take your phone calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's your show america
the phone call is free triple eight
eight two five
two is how you jump in let's start it
off the shower with randy
in cincinnati ohio randy how can we help
hey um how you guys doing we're living
the dream what's going on with you
all right good living dream myself so my
question is
is i plan on replacing my truck that i
have now of
13 years and is it wise to
buy new if paying cash or to
play with another used one i've had it
for 13 years
and i'm on a two-year program of saving
money to pay cash
with the plans is to have approximately
about
60 000 to spend to replace it
that's a great question man you have any
other debt
uh actually only our mortgage thank you
jesus there you go good for you
so the question is this i'm going to
have 60 thousand dollars
cash that i could spend on the vehicle
right that's a nice truck by the way
and uh you're gonna get a new truck is
this sixty thousand dollars
on top of your three to six months randy
or is or is this sixty thousand dollars
that you have total in the bank
uh so i'm actually
we lost and plans to have fifty thousand
dollars
so we already have six months okay
yeah this is all towards your truck
you've been saving this outside of the
baby steps
yeah okay great correct so and in march
of 2022
i should have 60 000 right cool
and what's your um what's your household
income
annually uh about 110 000
cool so what we recommend here is that
your vehicles
should not add up to be more than 50 of
your household income
okay the value of your car so if you're
making a hundred and ten thousand this
means that you should be right around a
fifty five
thousand dollar car in your possession
so and if you wanna stretch it this to
60 because you're paying cash for it
with that yeah i'm not going to say him
oh no no no no but if you come to me and
say yeah i want to buy a hundred
thousand dollar car
cash and i make a hundred thousand
dollars a year no
yeah no and then yeah go ahead yeah
no uh so is it wise to buy new
or should i stick to buy and use so my
wife my wife thinks it's a bad idea to
buy a new vehicle
listen man here's the thing you know um
the value of the car is the main thing
i would suggest used only so this way
uh someone else eat up the depreciation
um you know but if you find a car that's
brand new you're gonna pay cash for it i
mean that's on you as long as you know
you're gonna lose some money when you as
soon as you put off the lot
okay but the key thing here is you're
paying cash you're not using your your
emergency fund
um and the car's value is not anything
more than your
your uh salary so you can choose if i
was in your shoes
especially with uh my net worth being
below
a million dollars i'm going with a used
vehicle
yeah i think that's great advice and
there's not much difference between the
brand new one and maybe the one that's a
year old or even two years
exactly it's fantastic underneath the
warranty and everything
absolutely all right let's go to dayton
ohio now where we join
kristen kristen how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are you guys
we are having a blast what's going on
with you good um i had a question about
a parent plus
loans i know like we need to pay off our
loans like student loans
i'm on baby step two um and i was just
curious like do i need to pay off my
mom's
loan that she took out for me because i
know the bible says like honor your
parents so that's always kind of like in
the back of my mind
but she's also in like addiction so
um she doesn't really have her life
together i've been trying to locate the
loans but i can't seem to find like the
mail for
it um so yeah so let me get this
straight
your name is not on the parent plus loan
correct
i don't think so no because she took it
out for me
okay um and you are currently in debt
and you're paying off your debt right
now
correct yes so what i would do if i was
you
um is i'm gonna pay off all my debt
babysit number two
then i'm gonna stack up my three to six
months of expenses
once i cover that i'm gonna have a
conversation with my mom and dad
and be like hey mom and dad i'm in a
great place financially
i want to help um
and i would love to help pay back those
student loans
right now those parent plus loans are
not your obligation
i would focus on the things that you're
obligated with
get yourself on a solid foundation you
can stand on
once you get in a solid foundation if
you still have that conviction
of helping your mom then yes go help
your mom but right now
that's her responsibility because she
decided to do that
she decides to do that to help you
so i think you honor your mom and your
parents by
getting solid and then come back and ask
them
if if they would like your help yeah
kristen let me ask you this
she's dealing with addiction and her
life's a mess right now
um and so that's why you're having a
hard time just hunting down any of the
paperwork or anything on that loan she
took out for you did i hear that
correctly
yes that's correct um i aio's absolutely
right
i'm not adding anything to what he said
but when you get to that point
i and i think i'm hearing this in your
voice
you're concerned you don't want to give
her money to pay off the loan because
you're afraid what she's gonna do with
the money
um you could say that yeah she's just
such a sweetheart like she's the nicest
person ever
she just needs help no i get it but what
i'm saying is with everything ao said is
absolutely right
and because you're worried about that
you should be here's the deal once you
get out
once you get to that point hopefully
you'll be able to be able to get all the
paperwork and get directly to the loan
you can pay that but don't give her the
money you [ __ ] find a way
you can get on the phone with whatever
there's a way to do that and and i would
just not give her the money to pay it
off i would find a way for you to pay it
off directly
okay makes sense because you don't want
to contribute to
uh anything and she's not healthy and i
know she's a sweetheart and
by the way it rubbed off on you you got
a heart of gold too
but the point is is that you find a way
to pay it off
directly and not give her the money that
way it eliminates any temptation
and you do what you want to do but you
can't control that other stuff
you know what i mean yes thank you yeah
you bet good for you
good for you what a sweet sweet girl
here hearing in her heart man
yeah yeah she's uh she's great you want
to be careful there with family members
in that situation like that
never ever ever give them money and then
assume
or trust that they're going to do the
thing if you want to pay it off
go pay it off you go do it you figure
out how to do it and it just takes that
not just the temptation out for the
mother in this situation but also if
if she were to do that give the mom the
money the mom not
use it for the proper use and do
something that's you know obviously
leading her to
her addiction agreed uh there's more
guilt and shame on the daughter yes sir
and boy you don't want to live with that
so
tough situation kristin you're awesome
you're doing great things
we will be praying that uh your mom gets
healthy
great stuff anthony o'neil ken coleman
with you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
it's the ramsey show and we're here for
you america i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague anthony o'neil
as we take your calls about life work
money relationships mental health hey
uh we got ao on the desk today so if
you're single and you get some money
questions about relationships he's the
expert on that i always love those calls
i try to get them in here
this is so fascinatingly fun for me we
need some more single questions
single questions these merry questions
this yeah they bore they bore him yeah
they scare him too they really do scare
me it makes me want to stay single some
of these questions
oh it's always fun triple eight eight
two five
five two two five is the number triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to san jose
california where christy is on the line
christy how can we help
hey there thank you for taking my call
and i will definitely send my single
son to talk to you oh there you go send
them send them my way
well my question is um i learned uh
all how not to handle money from my
father
all these years that i just started
listening to the rambly show about 10
months ago
and in the interim here i sold my
business
and then an investment came in that
we had and that came in and after irs
and the state has
taken its big cut i still have
about a million two left over and
the only debt i have is a mortgage of
360
but part of me really wants to take that
money and help my kids get a house here
in california because it's so darn
expensive
um so that's where i'm at i don't know
whether i want to take that money and
pay part of the
you know loan off or kind of hang on to
it so it's cash flow
to be able to help my kids get into a
half so we have 1.2 million
cash left over from your investments
correct
correct and then you have 360 360 000
left on your mortgage that's it yeah
no other debt anywhere no cars no no
other debt
no other debt anywhere um that mortgage
was actually we
we took out that mortgage to buy a uh
rental property for my son to live in a
lot of
long story on that and and and we're
getting enough income on that to pay the
mortgage so
yeah i mean the mortgage is being paid
for so there's nothing out of our pocket
really
what's in your retirement but it is
what's in your retirement how much do
you have in your retirement right now
my husband and i have about 1.8
in our 401k and then we have
a another mutual fund of about 700
000 and then a couple of other things
here and there
that are about 400 000. that's fantastic
so you're looking at about like
2.5 million in investments
okay and then you have eight hundred and
forty thousand dollars
left after you pay off your mortgage so
that's what i'm doing
i'm paying off my mortgage i'm going to
jump on the phone with a smart vessel
pro
just make sure everything is solid as
far as in i would like to see maybe get
to about like three million
so that way you can live off the
interest of that you know when you all
are actually all settled
three hundred thousand three hundred
million could produce you i mean a
good amount of income a year that you
all can live off of debt free
and i kind of like the fact of sowing a
seed into your children i really do
i mean uh this is why we vouch for the
things that we do we want you to get out
of debt have a fully funded emergency
fund invest and be everyday millionaires
so that on babies number seven you can
be generous
and give and build wealth and so
um i'm paying off my mortgage okay with
that 1.2 million
that's gonna leave me with about a
hundred eight hundred and forty thousand
dollars
i'm gonna sit down with my kids i'm
gonna have a conversation and you know
what
i'm not just gonna give them the money
ken i'm gonna sit down and tell them
like hey
um you you're gonna get this money but i
want to have an
understanding that hey these are some of
the things i want you all to do i want
you to make good
good and wise decisions with your money
i want you to pay off your debt i want
you to do this
give them something just don't hand them
the money tell them like hey
i'm so into you we are going to sow into
you but i have expectations
uh with this gift um and i'm not going
to bring it back i'm not gonna take it
back if you don't do it but
set them up to win long term yeah okay
well i i can tell you that that two
other three kids are totally debt free
my
youngest son already paid off his loans
yeah um
and uh so basically our our thought
process is
is we would go in on the house with him
like as co-borrowers and then eventually
just
no no don't do that don't do that give
them the money and let them be young
adults
is this the same kid that's uh living in
the rental right now
no no that's the third one yeah and you
know what i heard
i heard some emotion in your voice i'm
not gonna make you tell us all
what it is but it sounded like that you
said it was a long story and i feel like
there's something going on there
that uh you may not be 100 sure
uh about how to give them this money
correct you got three kids
if anthony's right you got 8 40 left
over how much were you thinking of
giving each of the three kids
well i was gonna probably help the two
other two
only other two the one yeah the other
two the one that's living in the rental
i
i bought that house so that i knew as a
mother
he would always have a place to live
that's why we
bought that one is he paying you rent
okay
absolutely okay good yeah all right so
you're going to pay that off
and so you're gonna have no debt because
ao told you what to do and that's
beautiful that's a great asset for you
guys
but um i don't like the idea that it's
always a place for him to land i like
that he's paying you rent but i think at
some point he needs to put his big boy
pants on i'm just gonna tell you that as
a dad
but the other two how much are you going
to give the other two
um well i'm thinking about three to 350.
yeah all right so let's round it down if
it's or we were around okay 350 each
that's
so you still have 140 left yeah i i
would think through
i would think through all that i like
the idea of sitting down with one of our
smart investor pros you guys by the way
congratulations you guys are in
fantastic
position absolutely um and i'm with ao
as a parent i would love nothing more
than to be able to do something like
this for my kids i think it's great
um but i would just live that's my whole
thing i want to
i want to see it when i'm alive you know
i think it's great
these kids will get it someday when i'm
not hit oh yeah but i like to have
smiles on their faces when i can do it
i think it's great christy but i would
be wise about it and i would think
through it
and uh i would also think through
relationally you know you get the one
kid you've already done a favor for him
but if you give the other two money you
don't give him i mean i just
think through it as a parent this is a
complex thing when you get three kids
and you're giving about big cash
things but i think ao's advice was great
put some strings on it that
are related to morality and other things
like that that are value driven but yeah
nice touch here
to do this and again ao uh that's good
position man they're in phenomenal
position the 1.8 million and the 401 k
700 000 and another 400 so 1.1 so
they're right at that 3 million mark as
you said
absolutely and you know what ken here's
the thing when i think of babysitter
number seven i get excited you know one
of the goals that i
i have for me um and my wife whenever i
do get married we have kids
is that i i am i'm gonna make my kids
sign an agreement that they will never
tackle in debt
they will never have debt um and if so i
would give them
you know quarter million dollars um
minimum hopefully more by that time
depending on my uh financial situation
to go towards their house when they get
married that's their gift
but the agreement is that they will stay
away from debt
never borrow money um and i'm looking
forward to that because
i work hard and i get the babies at
number seven to be generous
and the most person that i really want
to be generous to is his number one
kingdom my local church
two my kids and then three my community
and so i think what she's doing is
phenomenal
um but i just think use this time to be
a blessing and then
also use this time to be educational
towards your kids
yeah i love hearing the mother's heart
there you could hear the emotion
um they've worked hard she and her
husband they've done a great job they've
been very responsible
um and and on top of this what the
advice you gave her
you know they're going to be able to
give cash away and
they're paying off another investment
exactly uh very easily so they still
have something to go actually enjoy
oh yeah absolutely right but that is a
beautiful thing there's nothing more
exciting
yeah for a parent than making their kids
smile and
as an adult see this is i love that you
brought this up
one of the other benefits of this these
baby steps is to get out there as
parents and get into that baby step
six and seven and be able to do things
for your adult kids too
yes you know because you never stop
being a mom
you never stop being a dad no matter how
old you are how old your kids are and
that is just one other
incredible benefit it's not just give
away to others but to give to your
family right
i love it really good stuff we got to
get you married man
we gotta get you married so you got some
little ones and you're doing all this
let's go
hurry up you see he gets nervous he gets
real nervous when i wish all that on him
fun stuff hey don't move more ramsey
show coming right up
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you are the next
greatest generation because you have
proven that even in adversity that you
have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
bad
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
anthony o'neil and we're taking your
questions triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five
our blinds.com question of the day
is coming to you shortly but first we
wanna make sure that you know that
blind.com
blinds.com rather uh is giving you 100
satisfaction guarantee and that means
even if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color which i did this once i
mismeasured the blinds they helped me
out
they did yeah oh man yeah because i'm a
disaster in this area
and they'll remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from noah in utah
he writes that i'm 23 years old recently
married i work full time in retail
making thirty six thousand dollars
a year this is the highest i've ever
been paid
i like the wage but i'm planning on
getting my bachelor's in biology to
eventually become a dentist i've been
interviewing for dental assistant
positions
to get into my career field but they're
starting out
at thirty thousand dollars a year is it
smart to leave
the job that gives me six thousand
dollars more
per year my wife's annual salary is
thirty
thousand dollars uh in this situation
um this is not a money decision only
if you can absorb the six thousand
dollar
decrease to get into the field and you
feel like being a dental assistant
is going to make you a better dentist
then i say do it
however uh you got to get the
qualification to be a dentist
that's a much more intense thing i don't
know that being a dental assistant
makes you a better dentist i don't know
that it
you know opens up positions for you as
much as you think so this one here
is a clarify and verify piece of advice
what i mean by that is
i talked to some dentists in the area
you're already looking at applying i'd
say hey
is this a good move for me
professionally how much more qualified
does this make me
how much more attractive of a candidate
as a dentist does this make me
if i can say i've got this experience as
a dental assistant
i'd want to get two minimum
three or four opinions from other
dentists on that before i would decide
to make this move
and then take the six thousand dollar
pay cut so i want to know a lot more
that's how you figure that i clarify is
this really going to be a good move for
me professionally
because on the surface it's not
financially right now but i'm okay with
that
if the professional benefits outweigh
the financial
deficit that's how you always look at
that ao i love it man yeah triple eight
eight two five
five two two five is the number let's go
to fort morgan colorado
alexa is on the line alexa how can we
help
hi guys thank you for taking my call you
bet what's up
um so first of all ao i apologize it's a
marriage question again
he needs to learn this anyway alexa he
can handle it
so i am a fairly new listener i
have been listening a lot to all of you
guys shows and
um i'm really i i love
doing different you know i love being
different and so hearing you guys talk
about
all of the baby steps and how
oh man it just makes me dream um i have
three kiddos
i am married and so the issue here is
that i've
mentioned um you know financial peace
university and the baby steps to my
husband
and he's not quite on board
i'm a little frustrated because i really
want to make it happen obviously i can't
force him
so i wanted to know your advice on that
why is he not on board
i don't know he's a little stubborn i
mean you know your husband
is not on board he doesn't want to pay
off his debt he doesn't want the
responsibility like what what's the
reason i think he's
really used to being kind of inside the
box
kind of thing you know like he's not
very
go out of my comfort zone kind of thing
and
i mean we don't have an emergency fund
right now
we just bought a house at the end of
last year
and he wants to go buy a new car
you know obviously finance no no not
cash or anything like that and so i'm
just kind of like
you know it doesn't make sense to me but
it makes completely sensitive complete
sense to him and he doesn't
um he's not very open to new ideas i
guess
um i've thought about possibly
trying to do some of it on my own and
kind of showing him how it works or
you know i don't know paying off some of
our debts if i do a budget on my own and
maybe then he'd be more open to it i
guess but
i don't know i don't know if that's a
smart move
i don't think a married couple it is i
don't it's not a smart move
um to have two different budgets in the
house it's not a smart move to be on two
different pages
as a couple um and again i think this is
where i
step out and let ken speak in from
a married perspective but uh there's no
way in the world anthony will be married
to a woman and we cannot come to an
understanding together if that ever
comes and we're going to counseling
because the only way we can move
forward as a couple is if we are
together
it makes no sense for me to be running
forward and she's still back there
it's going to cause even more issues in
my opinion within my house within a
marriage so
um i think right now we got to figure
out the money ain't the problem getting
out of debt ain't the problem
i think the biggest problem is getting
you two on the same page
period about the marriage is the first
step yeah i mean he
let's be honest alexa he doesn't have a
oh he doesn't like to get outside the
box no he doesn't want to be a grown-up
oh he wants all the toys he doesn't want
to sacrifice
he just wants to kind of keep going
along i'm guessing you guys make pretty
good money what's the household income
again
um we're at about 90 000
90 000 and how much of that do you make
um it's pretty close down the middle
i think minus 48. yeah i think i think
you have got to sit down with him and
he's got to see that emotion on you
i mean you were you were emotional and i
get it because you feel as though
uh your hands are tied you're you're
really reaching emotional desperation at
this point
and i understand why because you you see
where this is going
and you don't want this and you feel
like he's not even giving it a shot
so this again is a marriage situation
and i do think
a professional counselor who is
objective needs to sit with both of you
and he needs to see that emotion
he needs to know why you're emotional
and what
the future looks like in your mind
and he needs to confront all this
because this is a marriage
and it is not on you to try to budget
your way
and budget him into change he's got to
understand
uh oh my wife is serious
and uh so you guys need to have that
conversation that
you can't you can't you can't live this
way you're not going to live this way
and he needs to understand why and how
it affects everybody
and i just think a professional
counselor a relationship counselor or a
pastor
who has the gift of counseling needs to
sit you down
together and we got to get this talked
out because as ao said
this isn't really a money issue you guys
make 90 000 you can go make more
you can pay this off you understand the
baby steps it's not a plan problem
uh this is uh we're not on the same page
and
he doesn't get it yet maybe you've told
him but i don't think he gets it
has he seen or heard this emotion from
you
um not recently no
i just don't think he gets how big of a
deal this is to you and this isn't you
making demands
and threatening him i'm saying you got
to go i can't
i can't i don't want to live this way
here's why i don't want to live this way
it's killing me
can i explain why will you hear me i
mean a husband's responsibility
uh is to hear his wife to see her
and i don't think he's seen or heard
everything and if you don't feel
comfortable doing it
in your home then you need to say hey we
need to go to counseling and here's why
i'm asking you to do it i've already
paid for it i'm asking you not to go buy
a car until we can get on the same page
i'm asking you to stop uh accumulating
more debt
until we can get on the same page he's
got to know ayo
this isn't fun but it's got to happen
yeah
and then we find out how committed he is
to the marriage how committed he is to
her
i'm so sorry alexa that you're dealing
with this but this is worth fighting for
fight the right way getting a
professional to help is going to be
the way to go this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague anthony
o'neal
thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five
five two two five is the number our
scripture of the day ephesians six
ten through eleven be strong in the lord
in his mighty power put on the full
armor of god
so that you can take your stand against
the devil's
schemes our quote of the day from john a
shed
a ship in harbor is safe but that is not
what
ships are built for let's go to
cincinnati ohio where
karen joins us karen how can we help
hey i am very thankful to get to talk to
you guys i talked to anthony a few weeks
ago and he suggested i talk to ken
talk to you can about how to increase
my income to be able to pay off my
student loans but i don't want to have
to work myself to death today okay
all right i like this conversation so do
we have any ideas
of what you want to be doing the type of
work the maybe the career field
i'm in it right now and i've been doing
that since 1999 and i
do love it good so i'm happy with what i
do
but my ideal job would be something
working with animals but i don't want to
have to go back to school no i can't
i'm 54 years old you know no
you're 54 years young let's be very
clear
so how much do you make right now karen
what's your income
a little under 39 000. okay and what do
you do in it what kind of work what are
you qualified for
if i were to look your resume up what
would i basically come away with what
kind of it work
i do a lot of support do some network
cabling that kind of stuff
okay well i got great news for you um
you should be making with the amount of
experience you have in it and then i
think there's some certifications ahead
in your future
um that don't cost that much i'll tell
you more about that in a moment
but you you could be making 75 to 100
000 uh very soon if you got very
intentional and this has nothing to do
with working
60 hours 70 hours 80 hours a week this
is just a function of you getting
qualified
to do more technology work than you do
you're essentially help desk
uh somebody that kind of does a lot of
that right now correct
yeah yeah so let me ask you this you've
been in the tech world a long time
what kind of tech work if you knew that
you would be successful at it and you
got the qualification done what kind of
tech work would you want to do
um i really i really like the security
side of things
that's really interesting a lot listen
cyber security
karen is exploding it's one of the
fastest growing fields
period not just in technology and the
income is up there income is fantastic
you can make six figures oh within a
couple years of getting in it
it's not right away but uh karen
you do realize that that's just a
function of getting qualified and it
does not mean you have to go back to
college are you aware of that no
okay great so let me tell you about
bethel tech because here's what i want
you to do
in just a moment i'm going to put you on
hold and karen
if you don't call bethel tech and tell
him that ken coleman told you to call
him i'm going to be very upset at you
uh-oh
because i just wrote their name down
perfect here's the website
betheltech.net okay now i partner with
them on the ken coleman show i endorse
them
you know why i endorse them karen why
because they have a nine month
program nine months
and you can do it online and you ready
for this
if you're a ken coleman show or ramsey
show listener
because i'm telling everybody else about
it too
you cash flow your way through it they
give you a bigger discount it's gonna be
less than fifteen thousand dollars
they'll give you a cash option
you can cash flow monthly through their
nine month program
and they have an eighty percent
placement rate karen
in technology positions including cyber
security development all types of ruby
on rails all that stuff i don't even
understand
okay and you can start at 75 000
within a couple years you're making six
figures there's your answer now here's
the deal
there are other people out there so i
want to make sure people understand this
isn't just somebody that i'm endorsing
they really are doing this they're
already getting results for
ken coleman show listeners so go to the
website betheltech.net
call them say i talked to ken coleman i
want to know how this works teach me
more tell me more
you poke you pride you ask all the
questions at the end of the day if you
feel really good about them
then i want you to consider doing that
you can save up for it you don't have to
have it right away
but it's such an affordable option and
they're going to help you with placement
that's why i like them
you want to get qualified whether it's
bethel tech or somebody else
you want to get qualified with a
legitimate organization that can get you
the skills and also help you with
placement
because a lot of these companies are
looking for newly qualified
tech talent and here's what's great
about this i want everybody else to
understand this besides karen
every industry is now a tech industry
you think about the ministry world the
nonprofit world
healthcare uh just straight up business
everybody's got tech positions
so karen with your existing experience
and your talent
this is a no-brainer for you so to
answer your question
you need to get qualified and you need
to figure out who to best
qualify you to do cyber security and
it's not a four-year degree
it's not you may have to pay you have to
pay your dues a little bit
you may have to get in an entry level
but i got good news for you
you're gonna make more in entry level
than you are now doing help desk
yeah so that's how you make more money
and not work yourself to death because
you're 54 years young
right there you go karen i'll put you on
hold on
enjoy my kayak come on there we go karen
you can go buy a nice kayak make it 75
or more come on now call betheltech
uh go to betheltech.net talk to them
anybody else is thinking about this by
the way
ao for kids and parents i want to bring
this up for a second
there's some really talented kids that
just naturally gifted in technology
and they may not want to go to school
the entry into the real world is
possible
and it doesn't require a four-year
degree to get into technology
so you got some kids that could go right
into what i would call trade school
yeah absolutely you know technology is a
trade just like
electrician or plum or anything else and
so that's why i'm really
you know that's why i partnered with
organizations like bethel tape because
it's like you need to know
that as a parent hey if my kid is kind
of wanting to get in technology but i
don't want to college
that's not a bad thing right they can
get to make some really really good
money and the sky is the limit
especially when you think of the field
of cyber security where that's really
what it's all going to come boiling down
to
yes i love it really interesting because
i like that i never heard of that school
thanks for
educating us on that yeah i mean hey
when you and by the way they're just an
example
yeah there's other fields other
technology schools as well
do your homework can they help me get
qualified
to do the work that i want to do because
at the end of the day
um that's what it's all about all right
ao we got a question here what's the
question from amber on youtube
ao by the way the table with anthony
o'neal
crazy popular on youtube and the guy's
also blowing it up on instagram two
great places to get
video content for you youngsters your
parents out there he knows how to talk
uh in ways that people go hey i get that
that makes sense that doesn't sound like
some money expert
uh so check him out on youtube the table
with anthony o'neil so here here's a
question amber says
we're on baby step two and we make
eighty eight thousand dollars a year i
still owe a hundred and seventeen
thousand on my home
and i've got a hundred and three
thousand dollar student loan i wanna
continue my education but it's gonna
cost me thirty thousand dollars
cash flow to finish my degree as an
advanced registered nurse can you tell
me the steps
to take to do this yeah man here's the
very first thing cash flow
don't worry about paying off your
student loans don't worry about your
mortgage payment
um i would literally go to my scholarly
myscally.com uh they're going to ask you
to fill out a
nice long um
application in the application and
simply to see what all you qualify for
as a single parent or maybe you or
there's a lot of different things that
you qualify for and every monday they're
going to send you out of update of
scholarships that you actually
qualify for so get the scholarships get
the grants
and cash flow the rest of your schooling
now if i was you
i would call in and talk to ken coleman
and see if you actually need to go back
to school to get into your particular
field but if you and ken agree that you
need to go back to school to get this
particular field and
to get into this particular field my
scholarly.com will help you get the
grants and scholarships that you need
you're making good money to where you
should be able to as well help
uh pay cash for it then once you get out
of college then we're going to attack
the student loan debt
and get on to the actual baby steps
which is pay off all your debt using the
debt snowball then uh
get it three to six months of income yep
and by the way while we're on this topic
debt-free degree number one best-selling
book from anthony o'neil that
is just chock-full of a practical plan
and all kinds of tips
to be able to pay for that education you
need and not go into debt you can cash
flow it so i love it the cash flow king
on education he is anthony o'neil
great being with you friend thank you
hey i want to thank our producer ben
hill our associate producer call
screener kelly daniel
but most of all you america thank you
for listening this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay
advice in their life let them know about
the ramsey call of the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you